[Music]
[Applause]
say good morning to those watching on
peacock or those who were listening on
our radio Affiliates around the country
I heart radio FOX Sports radio as we
bring in Mike Tannenbaum the ESPN NFL
front office Insider and uh former Jets
general manager you can see him on get
up NFL live and Sports Center Mike let
me start with the question I just posed
how do the Ravens make this a positive
with Lamar Jackson moving forward
great to be with you Dan hey look Lamar
we're not letting you go you mean too
much to us we've put substantial offers
on the table and I know that from
Talking multiple people around the
league they clearly want them and what
they need to do Dan is say those crazy
people in Cleveland it's one deal I
could show you 20 other deals that our
deal reflects the marketplace we care
deeply about you you're 26 we got you a
new offensive coordinator and we're
going to stand shoulder to shoulder
moving forward and we're not putting
this type of money on the table if we
didn't think you were the guy that could
take us to where we want to go they can
still strike a deal with him
correct until July 15th and I would be
working around the clock to get a deal
done and here's why you want to lock him
up for the reasons we just discussed but
more fundamentally Dan the lead year
starts next week on March 15th right now
32 million dollars counts on their cap
if they do a longer term deal they could
lower that cap number pretty
significantly which you want to do so
they could go hopefully get a receiver
and other weapons to help Lamar so
there's a sense of urgency really on
both sides here
but it I I know that uh colluding is one
of those dangerous terms to throw out
there but when we realized what was
happening with Lamar the number of teams
who need quarterbacks almost all
simultaneously said we're not interested
in the Lord Jackson
not read into colluding with those teams
those owners who are trying to reset the
market here for quarterbacks
yeah it could be the right charge it's
the wrong time though we gotta pump our
brakes and here's why let's say we were
running the Atlanta Falcons we're going
to come out on the record yesterday and
say we have no interest in Lamar Jackson
because our audience is our Young
quarterback Desmond Ritter we don't care
about everybody else we care about us so
to me there could be collusion we're not
going to know that till May a lot of
things are going to happen in the off
season I was with the dolphins one year
we had Brandon Albert the number one guy
on the board was Laramie Tunstall there
was no chance we were going to get him
and obviously the rest is history the
point being is there's going to be some
Twisted terms what happens if Tennessee
loses Ryan tanhill maybe they go after
Lamar Jackson and pay this bill we don't
know so I saw the speculation on Twitter
we talked about it on get up the only
grade we could give that is a grade of
incomplete let's see what happens over
the next two months wait take us back to
the draft with Laramie Tunstall so
you're with the dolphins at what point
did you realize that that video was out
of him smoking pot
yeah so Dan this is a fascinating story
so
we have uh Brandon Albert at left tackle
the number one guy on the board is
Laramie Tunstall Tennessee for a long
time had the first pick they needed left
tackle Chris Greer who was GM I was the
EVP of football operations Chris's
credit he's like we should do research
on tonsil me and everybody else is like
we're wasting our time like he'll never
get to us so over those next couple
months we had done our research and then
the gas mask comes out right before the
draft like 20 minutes beforehand and
like look it was startling to us but
because we had done all the work we knew
he was a great kid he was young love
football great teammate
and Dan even as the draft started we're
like there's no way he's gonna get to
13. he was number one on our board and
we thought ironically Baltimore would
take him they took Ronnie Stanley then
it got down to the saints were like you
know Sean Payton will take him and they
obviously didn't and here we are with
the 13th pick in the draft we get the
best player on the board and that's why
like we got to pump the brakes on this
collusion because we don't know what's
going to happen I promise you Dan if you
and I are speaking in a week and a month
something is going to knock our socks
off maybe Derek Henry gets traded maybe
Trey Lance gets traded who knows what's
going to happen but the point is we
don't know just because a couple teams
came out yesterday to say that we have
collusion he's Mike Tannenbaum ESPN NFL
front office Insider all right uh the
Giants decisions with uh Daniel Jones
and saquon Barkley how would you grade
those decisions
yeah I would give it a D minus for uh
Daniel Jones in terms of they made a
massive mistake a year ago for 22
million dollars they could have put the
fifth year option on paying dearly and
let's put context on that Dan
they're paying 40 million dollars a year
they have so many holes let's take a
good young coin Jamel Dean at 18 million
dollars they could go get a really good
young Corner that this team desperately
needs so they overpaid because we just
all came back from the combine Dan
there's very few answers if at all in
this year's draft there's a lot more
questions they couldn't let Daniel Jones
go so they stretched to pay him now
that's the bad news the good news is
they were able to tag saquon Barkley and
it's amazing for all this discussion
around the league about running backs
aren't worth it three of them got tagged
and Josh Jacobs Tony Pollard and Barkley
Derek Henry's on the market what kind of
Market do you think there is for Derrick
Henry if I'm a team that's really close
take the Dallas Cowboys for example boy
I'm giving up maybe a second or third
round pick if I could pair him with
totally Pollard look out if I'm Buffalo
and I gotta figure out a way to keep Joe
Burr off the field or Patrick Mahomes
off the field in the second half of a
playoff game look out so I'm probably
giving up a second round pick because if
I feel like I'm close Derek Henry is
that good and Jerry Jones is on record
saying that they were going to make a
splash offensively in the off season and
I think we're all led to believe it's
Odell Beckham but I was wondering about
DeAndre Hopkins
he can be had and if I said you could
have D hop or you could have Odell
Beckham as your big off-season splash
who would you take
dhop he's just more productive and
durable I mean it's not even close when
you look at I love Odell he was the best
player in the Super Bowl two years ago
until he got hurt and here's what's
interesting Dan coach Parcells always
talked about the most underrated aspect
of team building was evaluating your own
and Jonathan gannon's coming in and they
may or may not evaluate their own well
like I'll tell you this Andy Reid never
take a player Andy Reid moves on from
because he does a great job of
evaluating his own coach
I mean Tyree kill maybe a little bit of
an exception coach Bell check for the
most part when he moves on from a corner
don't sign him my point is like they
have a lot of work to do in Arizona dhop
is an opportunity for another team to go
get a great wide receiver you were there
when Brett Favre came to the Jets what
would your pitch be like to Aaron
Rodgers if you were still with the Jets
three points I would make Dan well
Legacy Legacy and Legacy you win a Super
Bowl in New York you're on the pantheon
of all time greats and I'm talking about
Derek Jeter and I'm talking about Joe
Namath and Eli Manning and Phil Sims and
Tom Coughlin and Bill Parcells there's
nothing like the platform of New York
and the NFL so you win here you'll go
down as an all-time great
well he'll still go down as an all-time
great but he'll be an all-time great in
New York you know history but I don't
know what matters to Aaron Rodgers like
you know Brett Favre What mattered to
Brett Favre he wanted to poke an eye
yeah really poke the high of Green Bay
yes and I think being a great negotiator
and a great recruiter is being a great
listener and you make a really good
point that's important I would go out to
California or wherever he is I would
take a yellow pad and I would just keep
asking question after question what's
important to you hey maybe there's you
want to go meet Jamie dimon the CEO of
JP Morgan maybe you want to go to the
United Nations like whatever you want to
do we can do in New York and going back
to farv
he wanted to hunt and fish so Dan I told
him I'm like Brett if you come to the
Jets I'm going to find your ass is if
every Tuesday you're not hunting and
fishing and we took Google satellite
imaging of a farm that was 15 minutes
from the facility I'm like here's where
your ass is going to be every Tuesday
you can't be in the building so that is
part of you coming to the Jet and those
were ways that we were slowly it will
make progress because let's face it
there like you're a Northeast guy as
well but if you're Aaron Rodgers that
grew up in California and being Green
Bay or you're Brett Favre from
Mississippi the perception of New York
can be pretty startling yeah I just you
know Rogers is wired differently
and and then farv and you know farv I
could see where he wants to show the
Packers hey I can still play I don't
know if Aaron Rodgers wants to stick it
to the Packers does he
I do I I think when he came out on that
podcast a week ago and he still was like
emoting about well they traded up for
Jordan love and then I went out and I
won the nvp like hey Aaron you're an
all-time great like Jordan love was 4
000 transactions ago when you run an NFL
team you have hundreds of transactions
every year so who cares like this is
about you this is not about Brian
gudicons trading up for Jordan love so I
actually think part of it is proving he
could win and now the inverse of that
Dan which is really interesting is if
I'm the Packers I'm pushing him to the
AFC because I don't want to see this guy
unless it's in the Super Bowl so there's
a lot going on here but I think it's
clear the Packers are ready to go with
Jordan love I want to Circle back to
this before I let you go with DeSean
Watson's contract I've talked about if
I'm Lamar Jackson I'm playing against
this guy twice a year at least and you
know that he's making you know 40
million dollars more whatever it is than
your contract let's remove his contract
correct and I say to Lamar Jackson these
are your comps you know if it's Kyler
Murray if it's uh Russell Wilson Russell
like can you can you do that and say to
his camp
this is where we're going to be can we
find a soft Landing here for both of us
and is that the way you get this done
yeah I think that's one of the ways and
the other expression we use sometimes is
we're going to grow the pie so you want
230 million dollars guaranteed well
guess what he got that on a four-year
deal we'll give you I'm making this up
now 232 million dollars guaranteed and
we'll do a 10-year deal 12-year deal
like there's other ways you could do it
or we'll give you an incentive package
that if you win the MVP again you'll be
20 more than DeShaun Watson was so there
are ways but what happens to Anne
sometimes and I've been there
in particular a couple big guys like
Darrelle Revis like very notable
negotiations deal fatigue sets in and
that's what I'm concerned about here is
you've been looking at the same guys in
the room there's no agent the friction
goes up both sides having the ego and
now that landing spot becomes smaller
and smaller
I'll leave you with this Joe burrow
Justin Herbert
are they 230 million dollar guys
are they going to be asking for that
yeah absolutely I'll throw a third name
in there Jalen hurts as a second round
pick he's extension eligible now he
hasn't done it as long as burrow and
Herbert but he played flawlessly and he
played great in the Super Bowl dance so
this is an unbelievable off-season when
we think about the transformative aspect
of not only Lamar but those other guys
you just mentioned I think someone if
they don't get to 2 30 I think they're
gonna get pretty darn close yeah good
stuff as always Mike thanks for joining
us
okay thanks for having me Dan really
appreciate it Mike Tannenbaum former
Jets GM also work with the dolphins ESPN
NFL front office Insider and you could
uh see him on programs like get up NFL
live in SportsCenter